bianca stritt mit ihrem freund dann war
sie weg
bianca blumige vor zwölf jahren spurlos
verschwunden
was ist mit bianca passiert ist sie weg
gelaufen oder wurde sie opfer eines
verbrechens
[Musik]
was hat es mit den blutspuren aus
biancas badewanne auf sich und was kann
nach 21 jahren dieser schritt zur
aufklärung beitragen
unser cold case heute der wirft wirklich
eine menge fragen auf am 6 august 2000
da streitet bianca blömecke mit ihrem
freund sven el-nachbarn die höheren das
geschreie das gekreische und dann
plötzlich stille nichts mehr aber
niemand ruft an diesem 6 august die
polizei und bianca blumige die ist sie
zeit diesem sechster august spurlos
verschwunden ohne ihr geld ohne ihr
handy und vor allem ohne ihr baby unsere
reporterin katrin weuster die begleitet
diesen fall von anfang an und die hat
jetzt mit der mutter von bianca blumige
gesprochen
jeden tag blickt erika schneider in
essen von ihrem balkon auf die wohnung
aus der ihre tochter bianca vor 21
jahren verschwand
das ist natürlich ganz schwer wenn wenn
geburtstage sind oder hochzeiten
ich natürlich mit bankern nicht mehr
erleben kann
bianca hat eine glückliche kindheit und
weiß schon als teenager in dass sie früh
mutter werden möchte mit 18 jahren lernt
sie erkennen im januar 2000 bringt sie
ihren gemeinsamen sohn zur welt doch der
lernt seine mutter nie kennen wächst bei
einer pflegefamilie auf denn am 6 august
2000 verschwindet bianca bis heute
spurlos hat vaters wenn etwas damit zu
tun
seit biancas verschwinden berichtet bild
reporterin katrin weuster immer wieder
über den fall
süßer fratz hoffentlich ist deine mama
einfach nur weg gelaufen wie anders
tritt mit ihrem freund dann war sie weg
bianca blumige vor zwölf jahren spurlos
verschwunden
als wir bei diesem ersten termin bei den
eltern waren und die suche anlegt hat
auch der ex freund der vermissten noch
vehement mit gesucht hat sich mit
flugblättern fotografieren lassen das
hat sich dann geändert als er
zwischenzeitlich in den wochen und
monaten danach von der polizei auch als
verdächtiger geführt wurde was ist mit
ihm passiert ist sie weg gelaufen oder
wurde sie opfer eines verbrechens
[Musik]
was hat es mit den blutspuren aus
biancas badewanne auf sich und was kann
nach 21 jahren dieser schrubber zur
aufklärung beitragen
bei der vermisstenfall von bianca gehen
wir ja mittlerweile auch von
tötungsdelikt aus
bei tötungsdelikten kann halt jeder
hinweis die das kleine puzzlestück für
uns relevant sein
bianca blumige ist einer der
rätselhaftesten fälle deutschlands erika
schneider biancas mutter will endlich
gewissheit was mit ihrer tochter
passiert ist
essen vogelheim fünf kilometer nördlich
der city in diesem mehrfamilienhaus
wohnt bianca blumige im jahr 2000 mit
ihrem sohn bis zu dem tag an dem sie
verschwindet von sven l ist sie frisch
getrennt
ich stehe hier vor dem haus in dem erika
schneider die mutter der vermissten
bianca blömecke wohnt frau schneider ist
genau hierher gezogen weil keine 100
meter entfernt man sieht es dort drüben
das haus ist in dem bianca zuletzt
gewohnt hat aus diesem haus ist sie am
6.8 2000 verstorben durch den direkten
blick auf biancas alte wohnung fühlt
sich erika schneider ihrer tochter ein
stückchen näher mit sven dem vater ihres
kindes hatte bianca oft streit
[Musik]
ich würde mal so abschätzen dass sie so
anderthalb jahre bis zwei jahre zusammen
war wobei sie ja im dezember 990 schon
ausgezogen ist weil er jenem bauch
getreten hat wieso hochschwanger war gab
es am 6 august 2000 einen streit der
tödlich endete die beziehung zwischen
diana und sven war schwierig doch trotz
der übergriffe und der trennung blieb
bianca immer in verbindung zum vater
ihres kindes
die ankam hat aber trotzdem kontakt zu
ihm aufrechterhalten weil sie wollte
dass ihr kind kontakt zum vater hat weil
sie selbst hat sehr darunter gelitten
dass ihr kein ihr vater keinen kontakt
heute und er hat natürlich dann auch auf
das kind aufgepasst wenn sie bei mir
geändert hat
unweit des fußballstadions von rot weiss
essen betreibt erika im august 2000 eine
kneipe wo ihr die anker am 58 bis fünf
uhr morgens aushilft sie lernt einen
jungen mann kennen mit dem sie das lokal
verlässt dort sieht erika ihre tochter
zum letzten mal biancas kleidung aus
jener nacht hat sie aufbewahrt wenn sie
das so anfassen sind sie dann zurück war
dieser nacht vor 21 jahren als sie mit
ihnen zusammen in der gaststätte
gekellnert hat ich sehe auch immer noch
vor mir in der kneipe und wie sie dann
nach dem taxi gesessen hat und
für gefahren ist wie hier dann noch
gesagt habe ich lieb dich und pass auf
dich auf und sie sagt er auch maßgeblich
am nächsten morgen werden die anker und
ihr ex freund sven l von nachbarn
gesehen wie sie zusammen in die wohnung
gehen es kommt wieder zum streit etwa
aus eifersucht am nachmittag telefoniert
erika zum letzten mal mit ihrer tochter
ja ich habe da noch mal mit ihr so gegen
14 45 telefoniert
und sagte ich sage alles in ordnung sagt
mama dr ich sagte ihm jetzt ja braucht
gar nicht mehr wiederkommen ich will gar
nicht mehr sehen ich gehe jetzt in der
wanne
eine stunde später versucht erika ihre
tochter erneut zu erreichen aber sven
geht ans telefon immer wieder ruft erika
an jedes mal hört sie etwas anderes
warum geht er nicht ans telefon
das war sehr untypisch aber das ist mir
in dem moment gar nicht aufgefallen weil
er mir sagte er sie sind wanne oder
sie ist mein kind beschäftigt oder sie
ist eine bohne zigaretten holen
vom gefühl her sage ich so wenn im
nachhinein wenn ich mein spiel kam mir
das schon komisch vor aber mein kopf
wollte sich realisieren um 16.30 bringt
wenn das kind zu oma hedwig schneider
er erzählt dass bianca und ihr streit
hätten und sich in ruhe aussprechen
müssten kurze zeit später holz wenn er
das kind wieder ab und erklärt bianca
sei nicht mehr in die wohnung
zurückgekehrt
meine mutter ist dann ein sonntag gegen
amt ist ja dann rüber im biancas wohnung
und weil er da gama an dem wochenende
hat sie dann gespült und hat auch das
badezimmer ein bisschen saubergemacht
und meine mutter hat am blut in der
wanne gefunden und hat sich aber gedacht
in der regel gab unterhalt nicht
weggemacht eine mögliche spur wird
vernichtet war es menstruationsblut oder
blut einer verletzung
und der karte auf floor woche dann hatte
ihm noch einmal wasser gemacht will
putzzeug
hat ihm den draußen fototouren gestellt
hat gesagt hier den slopestyle jetzt und
da war er schon so nervös dass er den
eimer umgestoßen hat hatte sven etwas zu
verbergen und meine mutter sagte er hat
sich auf fensterbank hat er gesessen hat
auf die straße geschaut und hat immer
gesagt jetzt ist schon wieder hier
vorbeigefahren die bank hat aber weder
führerschein auto
also alles sehr mysteriös um 23 uhr ruft
erika das letzte mal an wieder behauptet
wenn bianca sei nicht nach hause
gekommen als erika in die wohnung kommt
findet sie aber geldbeutel schlüssel und
handy der verschwundenen nur ihr ausweis
fehlt 24 stunden später startet erika
nun eine suchaktion doch bianca bleibt
verschwunden nach vier tagen suche gibt
erika vermisstenanzeige auf ihr eindruck
die polizei handelt zu zögerlich wenn
dann zu vermisstenstelle hinwollten
vermisstenanzeige aufgegeben und die
dame hat mich dann aber regelrecht
ausgelacht und hat gemeinsame linie
anstellen 19-jährige verschwindet immer
gesagt wenn man ich kenne mein kind und
ist dann auch unter auch unter zwang
sind sie dann mit mir in bernkastel
umgegangen
auch die durchsuchung der wohnung bleibt
ergebnislos und ist wochen später
berichten nachbarn gegenüber erikas
mutter von einem heftigen streit
[Musik]
[Applaus]
über die nachbarn die haben auch ein
knall gehört und dann war ruhe haben
aber ganz lange zeit nichts gesagt das
ist dann erst durch zufall rausgekommen
was ich dann später bei der polizei
angegeben habe und die wurden dann wohl
auch verhört die neue aussage der
nachbarn
die blutspur in der wanne und die
tatsache dass bianca verschwunden ist
ohne etwas mitzunehmen verändert die
situation für die polizei die
ermittlungen werden intensiviert
[Musik]
das denn wissen app ski ist ermittler
bei der polizei essen er rollt den fall
bianca blömecke wieder auf seine
vorgänger errichten erst ende oktober
2000 die von erika gewünschte
mordkommission zu spät über zwei drei
monate nach dem verschwinden von bianca
da wo die mordkommission eingerichtet
und dann sind auch durchsuchungsaktion
gestartet und auch die wohnung bot sich
angeschaut dass man die
unterschiedlichen gründen er ist alles
ja die nicht optimal gelaufen sind das
macht dann das ermittelten
hartz iv in seiner ex freundin bianca
etwas angetan die polizei hat wenn's
handy ab und sucht nach möglichen
leichen ab lagerorten auch das
ufergelände am rhein herne kanal wo
bianca und sven häufig waren wird
abgesucht erika schneider war dort oft
mit bianca spazieren heute geht sie die
strecke mit reporterin katrin weuster ab
es ist der ort wo sie vielleicht genau
dort auch gesessen hat mit ihnen genau
auf diesem stück gras auf diesen steinen
haben sie das zusammen erlebt und jetzt
fehlt ihnen dieses das fehlt natürlich
und das 21 jahre lang
die suchaktion am ufer und im wasser ist
seinerzeit erfolglos trotzdem kommt es
am zweiten mai 2001 aufgrund der aussage
der nachbarn zur festnahme von bianca
sex freund sven er gilt als
hauptverdächtiger und wird bei der
polizei vernommen doch die beweise gegen
ihn reichten nicht aus er kommt
schließlich auf freien fuß
die spuren führen ins nichts der fall
bianca blömecke wird zum count case
bianca sohn justin ist mittlerweile 21
zuerst wächst der bei seinem vater auf
kommt aber dann in eine pflegefamilie
obwohl erika schneider den kontakt zu
ihrem enkel sucht kommt es nur zu
einzelnen treffen alles was ihr bleibt
ist die erinnerung an ihre tochter es
ist natürlich ganz schwer wenn wenn
geburtstage sind oder hochzeiten
gehe ich natürlich mit bern kann nicht
mehr leben kann
ich möchte bianca nur noch finden
dass ich es begraben kann und das hat
dann auch anfangen grund zu trauern weil
auch das konnten wir die ganzen jahre
nicht wahr wer irgendwann mit der suche
beschäftigt sind ich bin so ein
schwebezustand
1 prozent sagt ja vielleicht doch noch
lebte und wir haben wir sagt es
unmöglich sie uns tot sein
die polizei sucht auch heute 21 jahre
später noch nach zeugen wer hat am 6
august 2000 etwas beobachtet an biancas
wohnung in der vogelheimer straße 114
oder in der wohnung wo es wenn bei
seinem vater wohnte ein paar häuser
weiter oder am rhein herne kanal wo sie
sich gerne aufhalten
wer kann zu biancas verschwinden etwas
aussagen
der ermittler dass den wisnewski wertet
sämtliche damals gesicherten gegenstände
des cold cases noch einmal neu aus
[Musik]
im jahr 2000 war ja auch schon die dna
analyse möglich aber heute kann man viel
feiner viel besser suchen man hat viel
bessere wissenschaftliche methoden um
eine dna heraus zu finden
von der analyse dieses stoffes in einem
speziallabor erhofft sich der ermittler
neue erkenntnisse über die tat es geht
um blutspuren
man kann nämlich auch feststellen
mittlerweile woher die dna aus dem
körper stammt ist die sogenannte er eine
untersuchung und
das ist jetzt hier in dem fall quasi
auch angewendet worden die ermittler
wollen wissen befindet sich auf dem
schuber menstruationsblut oder das blut
innerer und äußerer verletzungen doch
brauchbare hinweise ergibt die analyse
nicht zudem werden die ermittler auf
einen speziellen spürhund aufmerksam
flintstones seine fähigkeiten sind
europaweit gefragt anfang des jahres
wird er auf einem essener brachgelände
eingesetzt
bring store ist ein archäologie hund dh
der ist darauf spezialisiert die lego
polen zu finden also die bestattungen
und das macht er insofern weil er die
die knochen riechen kann zehn meter tief
reicht sein spürsinn wird er fündig legt
er sich auf den boden und bellt flint
stone hat schon 17 mordfälle aufgedeckt
im fall bianca wurde er allerdings nicht
fündig noch nicht
nicht so doch trotz sind wir auch in der
belegung den hund nach wie vor weiter
einzusetzen um die mögliche
örtlichkeiten
abzusuchen ja um den ablageort dann zu
finden
totschlag verjährt nach 20 jahren daher
könnten mögliche mitwisser heute eine
auskunft geben ohne strafrechtlich
verfolgt zu werden darauf hofft der
ermittler
vielleicht hat sich auch der täter einen
anderen menschen gegenüber offenbart und
die person die suchen ja also die mit
besser die hinweise geben können was mit
mir damals geschehen ist
erika schneider konnte mit hilfe von
spendengeldern eines vereins eine
belohnung in höhe von 3600 euro ausloben
für hinweise die zu überführen
keine angst mehr haben vor einer
verurteilung egal was passiert ist bitte
sag mir wo werke ist
denn
ich bin bin auch nicht mehr
zornig oder wütend auf dich die zeiten
sind vorbei ich möchte nur bianca finden
damit ich und meine familie abschließen
können mit der suche
wer kann etwas sachdienlich es zur
aufklärung beitragen und helfen sie den
fall bianca blömecke endlich aufzuklären
hinweise an das polizeipräsidium essen
unter
829 0
[Musik]
und wir haben es gerade gesehen viele
indizien haben damals biancas freund
sven l in den fokus der ermittler
gerückt er verstrickte sich in
widersprüche und saß damals sogar ein
paar tage in u-haft aber zu einer
anklage ist es nie gekommen keine
beweise keine leiche und kein prozess
aber natürlich hat uns ja alle
interessiert was er nach all den jahren
über den fall denkt und unsere
reporterin die hartz wenn er nochmal
aufgespürt ja und seine reaktion auf
unsere kamera die hat uns ja alle
wirklich überrascht
[Applaus]
dürfen wir sie mal kurz was fragen
ja kein wort nur einen schlag auf unsere
kamera eingefangen hat diese szene
unsere reporterin katrin weuster die uns
jetzt zugeschaltet ist also gut namen
katrin
hand und sagt uns einmal wie hast du
diesen moment erlebt mit sven l
ja ich wusste ja auch nicht genau was
auf mich zukommt da ich ja auch ihn im
letzten 20 jahren nicht gesehen hatte
und in dem moment wirkt er auf mich
einfach nur sehr entschlossen das ging
alles sehr schnell in der sequenz sieht
man ja auch dass er keinen moment zögert
mit seiner reaktion
ich hatte auch nicht den eindruck dass
es für ihn einen moment des nachdenkens
des der überlegung gab ob es vielleicht
eine option sein könnte mit uns ein
gespräch zu führen das war also nicht
der fall gleichzeitig war er sehr
kontrolliert geht erregt sich nicht auf
er jagt uns nicht weg er greift nach der
kamera und geht dann ganz entspannt
weiter zum haus durch und ist
verschwunden das war so mein eindruck in
der sekunde katrin ich habe es gesagt du
begleitet diesem fall ja wirklich von
anfang an warum war es jetzt so wichtig
für dich nochmal mit 20 zu sprechen
für mich war der wesentliche grund
natürlich dass wenn er nachweislich der
letzte mensch ist von dem wir wissen
bianca lebend gesehen hat natürlich
hätte ich gern gehört wie war sie in dem
moment wie es sie ihm vorgekommen was
könnte seine theorie für das
verschwinden sein das hätte ich ihnen
gerne gefragt und ich hätte ihn auch
gerne gefragt wie er das seinem sohn all
die jahre vielleicht auch vermittelt hat
diese mutter die nicht mehr da ist das
kind war wenige monate alt das während
die vordringlichen fragen gewesen die
ihm gestellt hätte katrin zum abschluss
einmal könnte aber auch alles ganz
anders sein könnte es auch einen völlig
anderen täter geben der etwas mit dem
verschwinden von bianca zu tun hat
ja selbstverständlich klares ja wir
haben ja auch den ermittler den herrn
business gehört es gibt keine leiche es
gibt seit august 2000 keinen anderen
bekannten aufenthaltsort der bianca
blömeke es gibt keine ausreichenden
belastenden spuren für den damaligen
hauptverdächtigen ist könnte jedes
szenario letztendlich möglich sein wir
wissen es eben nicht und genau das ist
ja auch der grund weshalb die polizei
essen jetzt diese anstrengung noch mal
unternimmt um jeder spur nachzugehen und
vielleicht auch völlig neue
ermittlungsansätze zu gewinnen und
gerade wenn du bleibst für uns an diesem
fall dran vielen vielen dank für deine
recherchen und alles gute
ja es ist wirklich ein fall der ans herz
geht seit 21 jahren da hofft die familie
von bianca blumige darauf dass der fall
endlich aufgeklärt wird wenn sie doch
noch etwas wissen was eben das leid von
biancas familie endlich beenden kann
dann melden sie sich bei der polizei
essen unter 0201
829 0
[Musik]